[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de
télé fils voici les principaux titres en
images de ce 28 février 2010 est la
caisse d'allocations familiales des
yvelines des ménages à versailles l
immeuble réalisée par nexity sera
implanté dans le quartier des chantiers
à la pose de la première pierre vient
d'avoir lieu fin des travaux en 2018
en plein salon de l'agriculture nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des
yvelinois présent de la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet à la ferme d
alu et et puis rencontre au cours de
cette édition avec luna petite fille de
10 ans atteintes d'infirmité motrice
cérébrale et ses parents installés à
plaisir fédère les familles dans une
situation similaire à travers
l'association un geste en plus un mot de
politique pour débuter et un candidat
supplémentaire à l'investiture les
républicains dans la troisième
circonscription nicolas tardy joubert
conseiller régional du parti chrétien
démocrate entend prendre la succession
d'henri guaino actuel député qui n'a pas
reçu le soutien de son parti après ses
propos à l'encontre de françois fillon
ancien coordinateur de la manif pour
tous dans les yvelines il est
aujourd'hui en compétition avec le maire
du chesnay le conseiller départemental
philippe brillault qui a d'ores et déjà
annoncé qu'il serait candidat lui avec
ou non le soutien des républicains
nouveau bâtiment pour nouvelle vie le
siège social de la caf des yvelines
quittera en 2018 saint quentin en
yvelines pour s'installer
je vous le disais en titre du côté de
versailles ce midi élus et responsables
de l'organisme ont posé la première
pierre d'un projet vieux de quatre ans
coût de l'opération 30 millions d'euros
précision est nicolas kirilow vite ses
victoires gaudin un site flambant neuf
de près de 7000 m² est cinq étages
largement vitrée un espace vert à
proximité le futur siège social de la
caf des yvelines se veut moderne dans un
quartier complètement repensé à côté de
la gare de versailles chantiers
un immeuble massif la caf se sont en
sorte quatre ou trois immeubles reliés
par des éléments vers une terre soit ça
de l'extérieur ça formera un ensemble je
pense assez vivant donc on pense
toujours à l'urbanisme ce qu'est ce
qu'il ya autour
la pose de la première pierre du
bâtiment s'inscrit aussi dans une
nouvelle stratégie immobilière la caf
des yvelines disposera l'été 2010 8,2
deux sites pour l'ensemble du
département contre 8 il y a encore trois
ans ainsi le siège de social quittera
saint quentin en yvelines pour se
rapprocher du coeur administratif du
département pour les allocataires
évidemment ce serait bien plus simple de
se rendre à la gare des chantiers avec
tous les moyens de transport modernes et
puis avec nos partenaires aussi nos
partenaires qui sont effectivement
naturel le conseil départemental la
préfecture qui sont effectivement à la à
versailles et qui ne sont pas récents à
saint quentin dans les yvelines plus de
deux cent vingt mille personnes
perçoivent tous les ans des prestations
sociales de la caf pour un montant total
de 1,2 milliard d'euros
nous l'avions reçu en plateau il y a
quelques semaines nina miolane c'est une
jeune chercheuse en médecine numérique
originaire des yvelines lauréate du prix
l'oréal unesco pour les femmes et la
science en 2016
elle effectue des interventions dans les
collèges et dans les lycées du
département avec pour objectif est de
casser les stéréotypes qui entoure le
monde de la science elle était en
déplacement il ya quelques jours au
lycée jean vilar du côté de plaisir le
reportage est signée nicolas
kirillovitch pourquoi on pense comme ça
j'ai pas la réponse j'ai pas la vérité
révélée mais à mon avis c'est parce que
les seuls scientifiques qui sont
médiatisés sont des prix nobel lina
miolane n'a pas encore de prix nobel n'a
pas les cheveux blancs et ne semble pas
enfermer dans un monde parallèle
et pourtant la jeune chercheuse est déjà
reconnue pour son travail
à 26 ans une thèse sur la médecine
numérique en poche elle parcourt les
établissements scolaires yvelinois pour
tenter de contrer les idées reçues qui
entoure son travail
imagine tout de suite un homme blanc en
blouse bleue avec des cheveux en pétard
etc dans tous les cas pas une farine ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
convaincus que c'est pas fait pour les
filles et aussi que les filles sont
naturellement moins bonnes comme si à
notre cerveau n'était pas disposé à
faire des sciences en france moins de
30% des chercheurs en sciences sont des
femmes pire encore les prix nobel les
home trust 97% des récompenses nina
miolane à travers son parcours parfois
compliqué souhaite ainsi donner l'envié
aux plus jeunes de faire des études
scientifiques
moi je pensais que par exemple pour être
et en fait non elle n'était pas du tout
habillé comme ça même s'il a pas encore
beaucoup de femmes dans le domaine
scientifique je pense qu'il ya plus de
différence et la paille a plus vraiment
les stores et type de l'ancien temps je
pense que ça a changé
d'ici quelques jours la jeune chercheuse
yvelinois s'envolera aux états unis pour
la suite de sa carrière professionnelle
elle espère pouvoir y continuer ses
interventions pour les femmes et la
science
[Musique]
nous continuons notre série de portraits
d'yves linois comme chaque mardi cette
semaine nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de luna cette petite fille qui habite ce
plaisir est handicapé de naissance elle
ne parle que très peu elle se déplace en
fauteuil
une situation qui ne l'empêchent pas de
pratiquer de nombreuses activités
le reportage de camille lambert et de
julie barenton plus qu'un jeu le bowling
est un véritable exercice pour luna
tenir une balle synchroniser ses
mouvements autant de difficultés lorsque
l'on est atteint d'infirmité motrice
cérébrale à neuf mois les médecins
estimaient qu'elle ne marcherait jamais
mais grâce à ces séances de kiné n
arrive maintenant à se tenir debout et
se déplacer si luna on est à ce niveau
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à sa
persévérance patienter motivé la petite
fille de 11 ans investit dans chacune de
ces tâches elles arrivent en classe
de bonne volonté et c'est donc sa
participation est généralement très
bonne ils ont au sein de l'établissement
même tout un tas de rééducation et
ergothérapie psychomotricité kiné etc
donc c'est des enfants qui sont cons
faculté d'adaptation énorme ici tout ce
qui est rattachée aux scolaires est
appliquée dans la vie quotidienne pour
un apport concret exemple avec cette
recette de crêpes qu'elle remet dans
l'ordre une fois à la maison luna met en
pratique avec sa mère l'enjeu de tous
ces exercices est le même la rendre plus
autonome mais sans objectifs précis
j'attends rien je veux juste lui
faciliter les choses et et améliorer son
quotidien
je vais poser une question une fois de
savoir si elle était heureuse même en
étant handicapée elle m'a répondu que
oui c'est ça et je lui ai demandé s'ils
sont handicap pu poser un problème elle
m'a répondu non
la chose la plus importante c'est
qu'elles soient épanouis dont l'ordre
dans son handicap en épanouissement qui
passe aussi par le matériel ses
différents équipements lui permettent de
se déplacer ou de communiquer plus
facilement avec les autres comme cette
synthèse vocale qu'elle a depuis trois
ans ça permet d'avoir à s'exprimer aussi
pour pouvoir apprendre à lire et à
écrire
c'est important en fait qu'elle entende
les mots
quand elle appuie dessus en dehors de la
maison et de l'école luna pratiquer
différentes activités
elle va à la piscine chaque semaine et
pour la première fois elle se met à la
guitare
un moyen de s'amuser pour luna qui adore
la musique et surtout de solliciter sa
main droite qui n'utilise que très peu
habituellement on a surtout travaillé
avec la main droite pour essayer de voir
qu'elle commence à bouger un peu la main
droite pour faire des notes et moi j'ai
fait quelques accords avec la main
gauche pour que ça commence à sonner à
faire un peu de musique tu es arrivé on
a fait quelques on a fait quelques
accords exactement avec le pousse donc
donc on y est arrivé c'était bien on a
vraiment envie de montrer que le
handicap c'est pas ce pas une tare on
peut vivre avec un handicap on peut
faire des choses
luna a hâte de faire de la moto par
exemple vous faire du saut en parachute
et je pense qu'on le fera de toute façon
un nouvel équipement est en cours
d'acquisition pour aider luna a marché
des appareillages pouvant aller à plus
de 7000 euros pour pouvoir le financer
corinne organise des événements au
profit de son association un geste en
plus fin avril aura lieu un concert rock
à l'iufm de bailly
retour à l'actualité le salon
international de l'agriculture a ouvert
les portes ses portes le week-end
dernier à paris l'occasion pour certains
producteurs et agriculteurs yvelinois
aussi de venir présenter produits et
savoir-faire est nicolas kirillovitch et
nicolas landry était sur place et des
cochons des vaches des moutons près de
3200 bêtes sont mises à l'honneur au
salon international de l'agriculture et
par milices les animaux des ovins
yvelinois les mérinos de la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet c'était des
mérinos au départ et comme il séjourne
depuis plus de deux siècles à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet ils
ont été rebaptisés mérinos de
rambouillet je participe au jugement des
concours de races ovines sur la qualité
des trois ans en tant qu'expert lainiers
auprès du
concours général agricole il ya des
critères qui sont communes à toutes les
races notamment loge vérité c'est qu'on
essaye de rechercher une fibre qui a la
même finesse
depuis les pôles où elle est la plus
fine jusqu'aux hugo où elle est la plus
grossière prenons de la hauteur pour
rencontrer les producteurs pour sa
deuxième présence sur le salon
la ferme des à lui ai fait découvrir ses
légumes anciens des visiteurs étonnés
face à des produits comme le choucas lé
la poire de terre ou la racine de persil
monsieur
[Musique]
goûter on
cook hui comme une pomme de terre pour
ça
j'en passe 1
nous posent des questions à maintien
c'était comme ça simplifie je pensais
pas que ça pouvait comme ça en plus on
les éduque un petit peu on leur explique
comment le cultiver même les gens qui
sont qui viennent du sud de la france
ils disent 'voilà tient au salon on a vu
des légumes en ile-de-france qui était
formidable pour ce salon international
de l'agriculture 2010 est les
organisateurs attendent plus de 620
mille visiteurs jusqu'au dimanche 5 mars
agriculture toujours et le second volet
de notre dossier de la semaine nous
allons aujourd'hui partir à la rencontre
des acteurs du monde agricole dans les
yvelines avec les exploitants de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
environs qui se sont réunis sur un forum
organisé à saint quentin en yvelines le
reportage de michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacq de dixmude
donc il ya une cellule de blé améliorant
sur la droite il ya à peu près 160
tonnes de blé blé améliorant donc doublé
très protéiné pour notamment dont des
besoins de la monnerie julien thierry 32
ans est l'un des neuf cent cinquante
deux agriculteurs implanté dans les
yvelines
en 2015 le jeune homme décide de
s'installer avec ses parents dans leur
ferme de toussus le noble
il souhaite développer cette
exploitation de 300 hectares une
histoire de coeur c'est la ferme
familiale donc moi j'ai grandi ici
il ya aussi il ya un historique familial
puisque mes grands parents mes arrière
grands parents cultivaient ici c'était
quand même plusieurs générations qu'on
est ici donc il ya un attachement par
rapport à ça sur ses terres agricoles
julien thiery et son équipe récolte du
blé du colza de l'orge du maïs et de la
betterave sucrière une exploitation
rendue possible grâce à la fertilité du
département on a des terres notamment
sur le plateau de saclay
c'est des terres qui sont très bonnes
c'est du limon profond donc des très
très bonnes terres sur lesquelles on
arrive effectivement avoir de bons
rendements
je savais en arrivant
on va dire ce qu'il y avait ce qu'il y
avait autour et le potentiel aussi de la
terre donc voilà je me suis installé en
toute connaissance de cause agriculteur
passionné par son territoire julien
thierry participent ce samedi 25 février
un forum consacré au développement de
l'agriculture un rendez vous où se sont
retrouvés les principaux exploitants du
département
c'était notre but en fait c'était de
pouvoir rassembler les personnes
d'univers différents
les faire se rencontrer qui est du
dialogue entre elles donc après la
présentation des diagnostics il ya pu y
avoir au moment de la table ronde donc
des échanges entre les agriculteurs les
associations on avait des élus présents
aussi des communes donc ça c'est très
intéressant pour nous aussi pour qu'ils
puissent prendre connaissance vraiment
de la part des agriculteurs et des
associations
l'événement a présenté un diagnostic de
la situation pour les exploitants des
douze communes de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
les difficultés ont été abordés mais moi
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
solutions aussi d'initiatives qui
peuvent donner des idées d exemple à des
exemples notamment dans cette
imbrication entre les producteurs
agriculteurs et les consommateurs
citoyens et moi je pense qu'il ya des
choses à développer la dent dans ce
domaine une synthèse complète des
discussions abordées pendant le forum
sera rendu public dans les prochaines
semaines le résultat permettra notamment
d'enrichir les réunions à venir dans le
cadre du plan climat de saint quentin en
yvelines
et pour terminer ce journal regardez ces
images ses 580 visage dans la salle
d'exposition du conservatoire de
montigné à l'occasion de ses 20 ans
d'existence la structure a décidé de
présenter non pas les oeuvres mais les
visages de ceux qui apprennent en scène
y est créé cette saison les professeurs
se mêlent tôt aux élèves dans une
exposition à découvrir jusqu'au mercredi
8 mars c'est la fin de ce journal les
programmes se poursuivent sur tv fils
très belle soirée
[Musique]